lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
demostrar que el límite cuando teta
tiende a cero del seno de teta entre
teta esto es igual a 1 así que empecemos
pero esta vez
empezaremos dando una pequeña
construcción geométrica o
trigonométricas del asunto así que por
acá tenemos este círculo blanco el cual
es el círculo unitario y por lo tanto
tiene un radio de 1 déjame notarlo
este es el círculo unitario ahora cuál
es la longitud de esta línea de color
rojo bueno la altura de esta línea va a
ser igual a la coordenada james de donde
este radio interese acá al círculo
unitario así que por las definiciones de
las funciones trigonométricas dadas por
el círculo unitario la longitud de este
lado va a ser el seno de teta
y si quisiéramos saber que esto también
funciona para tetas que terminan en el
cuarto cuadrante lo cual va a ser muy
útil entonces podemos tomar el valor
absoluto de el seno de theta ahora que
hay de esta línea de color azul puede
expresarla en términos de una función
trigonométricas bueno vamos a pensarlo
qué valor tomaría la tangente de teta
bueno la tangente de teta es el lado
opuesto el opuesto entre el adyacente
así que si vemos este triángulo
rectángulo que tengo aquí y tengo al
ángulo theta en radiales entonces este
es el lado opuesto y este de acá es el
adyacente que es por cierto el radio del
círculo unitario por lo tanto vale 1
entonces esto vale 1 y simplemente me va
a quedar que la tangente de teta es el
lado opuesto muy bien el lado opuesto es
la tangente de teta
y como lo mencioné esto tomará un valor
positivo en el primer cuadrante pero si
lo quiero hacer para todo el círculo
unitario tomaremos el valor absoluto de
la tangente de teta esto porque queremos
tomar las cosas en el primer y en el
cuarto cuadrante ya que esto nos ayudará
a nuestra demostración ok ahora es
momento de movernos de aquí voy a pensar
en algunos triángulos y sus respectivas
áreas primero voy a dibujar un triángulo
que esté en este pedazo en esta rebanada
de pastel así que voy a construir este
triángulo y pensemos en cuál es el área
de lo que estoy pintando aquí como
podemos expresar esta área bueno sabemos
que el área de un triángulo es un medio
por su base por su altura y sabemos que
la altura de esto es el valor absoluto
del seno de teta y que la base es de 1
por lo tanto el área que va a ser igual
a un médium por uno por el valor
absoluto del seno de teta y lo puedo
reducir aquí con bom déjame ponerlo como
el valor absoluto del c
dt está entre dos ahora pensemos en cuál
es el área de este pedazo de pastel
completo de esta sección circular entera
como calculamos su área o dicho de otra
manera qué fracción del círculo es bueno
si fuéramos completamente alrededor de
este círculo tendríamos dos veces por el
radio entonces este de aquí va a ser
bueno de tam entre dos del círculo
entero y sabemos el área del círculo y
más de este círculo unitario sabemos que
su área es pib por el radio al cuadrado
pero el radio es uno
entonces me quedan simplemente pi por lo
tanto el área de esta sección del
círculo me va a ser teta entre 2 y si
queremos que esto funcione para theta en
el primer cuadrante y en el cuarto
cuadrante entonces tomemos el valor
absoluto de teta porque estamos hablando
de un área positiva
y ahora vamos a hablar de este triángulo
grande de este que tengo de color azul
el área que bueno es otra vez un medio
por su altura por su base toda esta área
va a ser igual a bueno un medio por la
base que vale uno por la altura que
sabemos que es el valor absoluto de la
tangente de teta así que puedo escribir
esto simplemente como el valor absoluto
de la tangente dt está entre 2 ahora
cómo podemos comparar estas áreas es
decir el área del triángulo de color
salmón con el área de la sección del
círculo con el área del triángulo de
azul bueno es claro que el área del
triángulo de color salmón es menor o
igual al área de la sección del círculo
es decir de esta sección circular que a
su vez es menor o igual al área del
triángulo de azul el área de la sección
circular es igual al área del triángulo
salmón más este pedacito de aquí y el
área del triángulo de azul es igual al
área de la sección circular más
este pedazo de aquí así que creo que al
menos de una manera visual te sientes
bien con estas desigualdades ahora sí
hacemos un poco de manipulación
algebraica y multiplicamos todo por 2 me
va a quedar que el valor absoluto del
seno de teta es menor o igual al valor
absoluto de teta que es menor o igual al
valor absoluto de la tangente de teta y
ahora en lugar de poner el valor
absoluto de la tangente de theta voy a
escribir esto como el valor absoluto del
seno de theta entre el valor absoluto
del coste de 9 teta esto es exactamente
lo mismo que el valor absoluto de la
tangente de teta y la razón del por qué
hice esto es porque ahora podemos
dividir todo entre el valor absoluto del
seno de teta
como estoy dividiendo por una cantidad
positiva no voy a afectar mis signos de
desigualdad y me quedaría esto dividido
entre el valor absoluto del seno de teta
esto también dividido entre el valor
absoluto del seno de tam y por aquí voy
a multiplicar por 1 entre el valor
absoluto del seno de teta y que obtengo
bueno el valor absoluto en el seno de
teta entre el valor absoluto del seno de
t tan bueno hechos 1 y del lado derecho
me quedo con bueno aquí estos dos se
cancelan y me queda simplemente un
hombre entre el valor absoluto del
coseno de teta ahora el siguiente paso
que voy a hacer es tomar el recíproco de
todo y cuando me tomé el recíproco de
esto se van a invertir las desigualdades
cuidado el recíproco de uno bueno
seguirá siendo 1 y ahora al tomar el
siguiente recíproco me va a quedar que
esto va a ser ahora mayor o igual y el
recíproco de lo que tenemos en medium va
a ser el valor absoluto del seno de tam
entre el valor absoluto de teta se
voltean
y ahora al tomar el siguiente recíproco
esta desigualdad me va a quedar como
mayor o igual en el recíproco de 1 entre
el valor absoluto del coste de beteta es
simplemente el valor absoluto del coseno
de teta y como sólo nos interesan qué es
lo que pasa en el primer y en el cuarto
cuadrante porque vamos a crear aproximar
la teta a 0 en esta dirección y también
en esta otra dirección por lo tanto nos
interesa solamente lo que pasa en el
primer y en el cuarto cuadrante bueno
pues en el primer cuadrante donde t t es
positivo el seno de teta también es
positivo y en el cuarto cuadrante teta
es negativo y el seno de teta tendrá el
mismo signo también será negativo es por
ello que estos valores absolutos salen
sobrando en el primer cuadrante tengo
algo positivo entre algo positivo y en
el cuarto cuadrante tengo algo negativo
entre algo negativo así que déjame
quitarlos y ahora observa el coste lo
que representa la coordenada x de
nuestro punto la cual observa no es
negativa
en el cuarto cuadrante y por lo tanto
podemos asegurar que será positiva
entonces también quitaré el valor
absoluto al coseno de teta ahora podemos
pasar un segundo este vídeo porque ya
casi tenemos la respuesta puedes verla
observa tenemos tres funciones puedes
ver esto como fz igual a 1 estoy acá
como head de teta igual al seno detectan
entre teta y está como htc igual coseno
beteta en este intervalo que nos
importan que es el intervalo para menos
y medios menor o igual a teta menor o
igual a pi medios este intervalo que nos
interesa es decir para cualquier ángulo
hay entonces esta desigualdad es cierta
por cómo estamos definir nuestras
funciones ojo se detecta entre tan bueno
ella si está definida para este
intervalo excepto cuando te está vale 0
para cualquier otro ángulo esta
desigualdad se cumple y aún así podemos
encontrar el límite así que podemos
decir que por el teorema de comparación
o del sándwich esto es cierto
el intervalo entonces sabemos que lo
siguiente también es cierto y aquí es
donde debería de entrar un redoble de
tambor porque el límite cuando teta
tiende a cero de uno va a ser mayor o
igual al límite cuando te está tiende a
cero de seno de teta entre teta que es
lo que estamos buscando que va a ser
mayor o igual al límite cuando teta
tiende a cero de coseno de teta y bueno
esto claramente va a ser 1 así que
déjame ponerlo esto es el límite que
buscamos y este de aquí a ver cuál es el
límite cuando teta tiende a cero de
cociendo dt está bueno cociendo de cero
es 1 y es una función continua y por lo
tanto va a ser igual a 1 entonces veamos
esta función debe de ser mayor o igual a
1 y menor o igual a 1 eso quiere decir
que este límite tiene que ser igual a 1
y ya con esto lo hemos logrado